could in the near future entangled
particles be used for non delayed
communication over vast distances yeah
so what happens in quantum physics is
that particles can know about each other
instantaneously at a distance mm-hmm so
that if you perturb one particle the
other particle which is entangled with
it can alter instantaneously faster than
they balloons across across the world
exactly I mean if you want to get sort
of macroscopic about yeah so twins in a
sense that one has a thought it's yeah
and the others like white is my hand her
dress like does your twin hit her hand
in the door exactly so we're this as
people report so yeah I'm not giving
fake science here I get that it's not
real so entangled particles communicate
with one another faster than the speed
of light it's very well understood it's
a quantum and that's a thing that's real
answer it's not just like a dream
everyone has that's real the problem is
if you want to do that in any way that
matters to life likes you know you want
to I don't know to there two worlds
there's a microscopic world in the
macroscopic level when you talk about
macroscopic things you want them to
behave in a microscopic way you want
them to behave quantum mechanically it
all gifts sort of averaged out the
problems you can have particles
entangled but so are other particles
trying to entangle in a different way at
a different time and all this becomes a
one macroscopic classical physics
problem where nobody is doing weird
things like what happens in quantum
physics so the big challenge is can you
bridge the gap between the way matter
behaves added smallest scales exhibiting
the tenets of quantum physics and the
large scales that we are familiar with
interacting and that there's no known
way you can end up doing that and so
right now it's a quantum mechanical
curiosity yeah you got a great question
sorry